comment lutter contre l'absentéisme des
collégiens en fin d'année scolaire en
organisant trois de football c'est
l'opération menée conjointement par le
collège réglée du bas de la rivière et
l'académie sportif de la redoute
il s'agit pour les élèves de continuer à
venir à l'école malgré la fin des cours
et des conseils de classe et de finir
l'année en s'amusant
pour les professeurs c'est l'occasion de
côtoyer des collégiens dans un autre
cadre que l'établissement scolaire
l'idée c'était les faire venir au
collège le plus longtemps possible et
donc que droite manque association
l'organiser fait par notre foot pour
nous pour nos propres ce qui est
intéressant c'est de côtoyer les
éducateurs sportifs qui qui voit les
élèves la folie et le samedi pour les
matchs et ça fait un lien entre les ducs
et toute l'équipe éducative et
l'association qui est pas négligeable
parce que ça nous aide aussi nous assez
c'est un levier qu'on a enlevé
supplémentaires avec les élèves
il ya des élèves qui sont vraiment en
difficulté dans le collège donc la
notation pour eux ce n'est pas dire
grand chose
donc le fait de passer de s'appuyer sur
les éducateurs sportifs
c'est une équipe en fait on est là pour
pour les pour les élever pour leur
donner confiance en eux et le
partenariat l'éducation nationale avec
les associations de quartier je pense
que ça va pointer un partenariat qui a
duré plusieurs jours et qui s'est
traduit par un tournoi aux différentes
équipes se sont affrontées en bas de la
rivière du football pour fédérer les
jeunes du quartier c'est l'objectif de
l'académie sportive de la redoute
l'objectif c'était de nous et un premier
lien entre les gens du village rédelé
qui sont aussi en foot à la redoute et
aussi dans le club voisin du sdefa et
l'académie sportif de la redoute
on a profité de la fin de l'année que le
brevet soit finie que les conseils de
classe soit fini pour proposer avec nos
deux emplois d'avenir et moi-même un
tournoi soit 3 jours pour permettre à
une quarantaine de jeunes de continuer à
venir au collège en pratiquant du
football donnant de façon respectueuse
et joyeuse pour les jeunes participants
et participantes entre le foot et les
cours il n'y a pas photo on s'amuse
chez moi ici dans le gymnase du bas de
la rivière qui ont été remis les
récompenses à tous les joueurs car même
s'il y a eu un vainqueur plus que jamais
la devise de coubertin devait être
appliquée le plus important est de
participer